[Musique]
partout je joue je dis à tout le monde
je m'appelle Diane je viens du Sénégal
c'est vraiment une opportunité de
pouvoir être fier de montrer à quel
point j'aime mon pays à quel point
j'aime le Sénégal
[Musique]
quand j'ai décidé de me mettre de me
lancer dans la musique on m'a dit non
parce que dans cette famille on ne
chante pas et on dit parfois musique
du coup moi je savais pas quoi faire et
je les ai dit moi je veux faire de la
musique je ne sais pas qu'importe ce qui
se passe moi je veux faire de la musique
[Musique]
je me suis senti seul c'est-à-dire
j'avais pas l'opportunité d'être avec ma
famille d'être souvent avec ma famille
je te noie de ma mère et mon père il
n'était pas là il était loin
[Musique]
une fois à Dakar j'ai activé mon activé
mon folie je m'en fiche de sujet de la
nourriture si j'ai rien moi je suis dans
la rue je demande rien à personne je
demande pas de l'aide à mes parents ni
personne je prends ma guitare et
commencer à jouer avec un ami alpha on
jouait dans les cabarets dans la rue
même quand il pleuvait on allait faire
des vocalises on faisait tout
et un jour j'étais à Colobane parce que
parfois je n'avais rien je prenais mes
chaussures je le vendais dans la rue
quelque chose et boum on m'appelle vous
dit j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous
messieurs
là où je suis il y a beaucoup de bruit
s'il vous plaît si vous si c'est une
bonne nouvelle laissez-moi vous déplacer
un peu est-ce que vous savez qui parle
avec vous non je sais pas c'est un
numéro sud-africain apparemment il me
dit c'est Monsieur J'ai oublié de de The
Voice
sélectionné pour les auditions à
l'aveugle The Voice Afrique francophone
et là j'ai crié
[Musique]
là je ne fais que la musique je ne fais
que chanter donc j'ai fini les études je
vais dire j'ai arrêté les études à un
niveau Master 2 Master 2 en littérature
africaine et poste coloniale en anglais
là je fais que la musique de la musique
je ne fais que chanter donc c'est ma
routine je suis venu ici pour chanter
quand je rentrerai aussi il y aura pas
de
fera pas de il y aura pas de vacances je
continuerai
[Musique]